planning to stream today I was only
planning to scream tomorrow but I just
found that the monthly bullet arena is
going on so this is gonna be a complete
bullet stream I already played a few
games and I'm gonna try and keep up my
streak it's gonna be a lot harder to
give commentary a while playing bullet
so just gonna try and play normal moves
work be one Bishop III 92 it's easy to
play a bullet when you have like clear
plans and I think I'm currently in like
350th
no 336th place so I'm gonna try and work
my way up hopefully by the end of the
tournament I'll break into top ten maybe
yeah this is a very maneuvering type
position where once like playoff four
and now I could breathe a bit easier oh
that was I have to take maybe I went up
on but B 2 is kind of weak there should
be six as a threat but she I don't think
you saw maybe we can trade Queens okay
we'll take a bunch of things d6 this
week don't trade that okay this is
looking very nice centralize that Queen
maybe go for f5 next oh he hung his rook
I 5 is still not a bad move so I win
this I want to trade I don't want to
trade his King is less safe just gonna
power on that file yeah Queen e6 coming
okay that was nice if anyone's watching
let me know let me know if things look
ok I should be live looks like the video
is okay not sure about the audio I
ordered a new microphone which is
supposed to arrive either tomorrow or
the next day so hopefully uh
the sound quality will be even better
later this week and I just broke into
the top 300 so life is good
four wins in a row I'm gonna try and
break 2500 this tournament - it's a hard
rating to maintain but if I'm in decent
form and I don't desert too much then I
should be able to get there okay we're
going for some time on of
oh I didn't want to play a five I wanted
to play a six okay well a five I guess
I'll have to make some sense of the
problem is he has might be five in lots
of situations so I don't know how that
moves going to be useful oh now it looks
okay it's kind of slow to attack on the
Kings side now I play a four eight three
and now he can't defend this Knights
this is very nice um he wants to attack
me what's the play of this move oh he
wants to play Queen g5 ah tricky do I do
here well Queen g5 is coming maybe I'm
not winning the piece okay well I win
the Queen that's nice and then yeah
maybe if you fake Queen g5 there I would
have had to play 98 and hello pyro lock
hello Tunnel or thanks main-sequence for
hosting it's hard to look at the chat
during a bullet game I don't want to
play b5 let's take this pawn just was
very annoying there and now there's no
more mating ideas for him I want to get
my queen to be two that's the ultimate
goal gonna sack and queen c5 hey it's
happening
nice okay 219th face
keeping up the streak other 1894 is a
good move Knight c3 I think I can take
this and maybe e5 and be aggressive I
guess he could take on d5 but okay he's
too scared
mm-hmm I want to trap the night let's
play h5 and then oh but then f6 Knight
g6 work h6 this is confusing this should
be good now though take their take their
free Queen everyone's hanging their
queen today people are so generous g6
solid I want to play like Queen f2 and
then Knight c4 and just win everything
especially the King take all the spawns
allama Lord in the chat it's a llama
Lord is like the world-record holder of
like fastest a moving mouse which I got
out like a professional gamer mouse but
I'm just so slow with it that's why I'm
sticking with the trackpad there's a lot
of pins here this is a fork my knight
controls g1 so you can't play rook g1
haha let's take everything taking stuff
there's my mates okay good game
moving up first place anyone good the
pouncer 2672 wow only lost one game the
whole tournament
I have to catch up to him okay we're
going to play some time on Irving and g3
let's play H 5 H 4
oh I hung my queen no okay well now I'm
giving him Queen odds that was really
unfortunate I thought I was gonna trick
him by playing H 4 quickly Thank You mu
P PI loopy for the three bits here I
need as much support as I can get here
this physician is terrible I'm low on
time he's playing quickly at least my
king is somewhat safe now I just have to
win his Queen oh that's a free Knights
right to win his Queen then life will be
fine how I win his Queen he wants to
take on a 7 mm that's annoying let's do
this and then take on me too
now I'm threatening a rookie to where I
would still be down at rook Wow I have a
massive attack now Oh where's my mate
this has gotta be good somehow Bishop h3
maybe wait I have to calculate Bishop h3
I have 19 seconds so I'm just gonna do
it
it looks crushing I have to take the
rook first and then that's mate okay wow
I guess my rooks kind of somehow
coordinated like one came through the B
file the other helped attack on the H
file that was nice okay keeping it clean
back to tournaments Antonio Gramsci 1900
let's play g4
this is a nice line trading the jeep on
for the e pawn it's just a beneficial
trade for whites let's play c4 Knight c3
I don't mind sacking the exchange like
if he takes with Knight yeah because
it's King so weak and h5 can't be
defended
now I'm either amazing him or if you
play King g7 I could win the bishop okay
your game
little [ __ ] little Plotkin also plays
with the trackpad yeah I mean if you
have a good track pad then it's it's
very possible to be fast and little
Plotkin is probably even faster than me
so it's a trackpad life I'm playing
someone higher rated than me I haven't
played a good right a decent player yet
I'm going into this line I've never been
this guy Wow time to get revenge
can i play bishop here no let's play
Knight f3 first and then Queen III I
think I was looking at slime the other
day maybe even yesterday he's attacking
stuff now I think I can do that and
maybe take and then d5 I actually don't
know what I'm doing here but I just want
to push the HP pawn now I sort of know
what I'm doing
also f4 possibilities um he wants to win
f3 let's play Bishop g2 ugly move it
kind of necessary and then maybe I can
do something at some point someday what
am i doing
92 and c3 maybe elastic hold thanks for
the cheer he wants to play Knight c4
this is really scary let's trade stuff
and my bishop is terrible maybe I can
play Bishop h3 and prevent rook c8 okay
mission accomplished
rook there I don't know if I'm getting
anything on the Kings side like he's so
solid I'm threatening worked a gauge 5
but he defends may be here in Queen B 4
oh but I'm losing f3 he didn't take it
that's nice
ah oh man okay well trade Queens he's
playing so much faster than me oh my
gosh I have to start pre moving ok I'm
attacking the knight and now I pinned
him but he can escape
ouch okay my bishop blocks off the file
I'm winning the pawn I'll I'm flagging
that's so sad
hey am I gonna win this oh my gosh I won
that Wow I had one second to ten seconds
how did I win that he hung his rook wow
I'm so good I don't even understand I
have to go back and look with the
timestamps because I was ridiculous
yeah he just he was trying to flag me
and he underestimated my speediness with
the trackpad okay hey I broke twenty
five hundred and I broke into the top
hundred that was just incredible last
like 30 seconds and now I'm playing a
1,700 keeping up the streak let's play a
semi sloth
I haven't played one of these in a while
a four is a forum move let's play c5
can't be good maybe it's reasonable I
don't know you might get into some yeah
now we're in an i QP position but his
bishops kind of stuck and my piece is
developed normally I played Bishop h5
rookie eights it's relatively easy to
play for black maybe you have 94 stuff
because there's some pin if you takes on
you four I probably take on you one so
he'll probably play rook c1 or not play
rook c8 lots of tension here I like my
pieces t4 possibilities yeah d4 wait no
d4 does that work can take on e4 I don't
know what to do maybe take okay I'm
gonna move my knight now they're nice
pinned on c3 bishop g6 possibilities -
okay this wins a piece at least Oh if I
take with Queen rook c1 a rook c1
doesn't wrap the Queen and that's the
free rook let's do this
okay good game yeah that was one of
those positions where the iqp is
actually a good good factor for a lack
because it just gives so much activity
okay next game let's play a London ooh
this is a different this is a different
line one of my pet lines I think already
a black should be in trouble it should
be for a note Bishop f4 I don't know I'm
so conflicted let's do this and then
Queen c6
okay well this is a fork oh he wants to
take on e4 but that's fine
oh I have a funny idea if he takes on b2
way it doesn't work as he as b6 okay
let's do this first
I wanted to play Queen a5 almost worked
play rugby one here okay night chief
of sevens a weakness set f7 is currently
defended by the Queen B sevens hanging
the ships attacked okay I'm gonna try
and go for the kill somehow oh is that
me that's made in three nice okay good
game
66 place keeping a clean Kanak good luck
let's play my normal stuff oh he's
playing some hippo reversible yeah okay
um so I just have to play quickly also
play good moves
hmm it's kind of annoying but d3 is kind
of a backward pawn so maybe I can
somehow double up nvm just trading
everything I'll still double up on the D
file I don't really want to trade Queens
but maybe I have to okay now there's
this pin that's nice threatening
something like Bishop c5 we're just
threatened rook take tea for if he plays
Bishop III I of e5 Wow blocks winning a
piece I think King III Bishop c5 the pin
is too strong that's a fork oh this is
gonna end very badly for him cuz he's
losing another piece and his King winds
up in some kind of mating net where's
the mates check this is God let me meet
somehow check with the bishop hey its
mate that was nice and it's opposition
sweets hey top 50 49th place I'm gonna
try and keep the rating above 2500 if
possible okay another victim ZB I see
let's play h5 I'm flying sagging in
exchange what to do maybe taken rook t1
oh he wants to trade Queens mm didn't
really want to allow that so I'm just
down the exchange maybe Knight b5 is a
good move I don't know when Castle
queenside if he doesn't take on b2 if he
takes on b2 probably rook b1 and I'm
threatening this and this and this
everything would fall I could take with
check King g7 Castle queenside his kings
being attacked maybe I have some mating
attack with my minor pieces before
explosive
wait that's c4 explosive nevermind what
do I do
he wants to play b6 wants to take my
bishop let's just retreat oh wow
I'm kind of confused here s4 yeah I
didn't see
to save that I was unfortunate and I'm
moving too slowly
okay I'm gonna reinforce everything my
Knights a super piece on d6 I cam down
the exchange but I have enough pawns for
it I just have to defend five and then
bring the knight in maybe a four he's
gonna play a five maybe yeah he wanted
to play for it but now I have the B 5
square could probably pre move that okay
oh but I take with check and then take
the rook now I'm up to exchange hello to
Eve eh oh I have to move quick but he's
about to flag okay that's a pin good
game the icebag exchanged like I calm
and then somehow I move slowly but he
moves slower a thirty seventh place
so not a two decent player I think I
play them already this tournament sleep
ooh the pest and we're going into the
sign we will take and then knight c6
this is a fine line oh he knows what
he's doing
maybe maybe not when a five guarantees
to win the pawn back this is just a good
position now s4 so weakening because now
his bishops kind of stuck I guess he
wants to play Bishop to e3 never mind
I'll to play d6 and I still try to play
this position we Rock f1 was kind of
random
I think I'll Castle queenside I'll keep
it positional because those pawns are so
bad on the C file and I'll try and
tickle him in some way we can trade
Queens double up on the e-file and then
maybe win a pawn that was probably a
good move
oh wait a minute what's going on here oh
he can't take on d6 cuz I take an ivory
key to check oh he has that move Wow
that works for him well done
but he's so long time he's winning all
my phones but it hopefully shouldn't
matter defend Wow
it was nice tactic by him h5 ouch this
is almost losing for me no he's gonna
make me no I lost a game oh hello 2x
villager his first loss that's
disappointing now I lost I really lose
over 20 points from that game I guess I
did
it was 2200 ouch
yeah I mean he probably deserved to win
that like he he found that amazing Ponte
t6
I couldn't take his rook kiss he would
Queen his pawn I don't know why I'm
playing a Slav let's play Cambridge
Springs this is a fun line I think it's
an easy line for bullet too because
ideas are so straightforward like a
three doesn't attack anything because
the pawn is pinned and now I think I
went up on though he might get comp oh
he's getting comp before I have to go on
a rescue mission for this Bishop b5
before they're okay
hey the bishop is going to be rescued
and I'll still be up upon and this is
fine yeah past a pawn good looking
pieces well just trade everything maybe
I shouldn't have done that but it's
still like
position I'll just have to be a bit
careful here don't want his rook to get
in maybe go for a five and then take um
this is actually tricky he winds up on
back ouch
okay I'll take all his pawns on the
second rank a counter play
I've always throw in some rookie to
check if necessary like rook a to just
simplifies this Kings out of place good
game
okay 39th place gonna try and get the
streak back also try and get the 2500
rating back okay uh VIN VIN slightly for
this game I'm just gonna do the Grand
Prix set up even though he didn't play
Sicilian and hopefully it works out play
h3 because my chief war would have been
annoying f5 and I'm just gonna go for
some attack maybe take 92 and g4 whoa
uh-oh
I didn't see that do I have to run I
guess I have to run
if you plates going off to I have 92 so
he has to take and then Queen f3 my
Kings a bit misplaced but it should be
okay yeah I will take and do that and
his nice trapped
Oh
counter play okay I'm still winning his
Knights he's gonna get the pawn to e3
and they'll build some impressive pawn
chain like he'll play c5 yeah what to do
let's put the bishop here going for c4
funny pawn structure Bishop a3 I'm gonna
win all his pawns whoa okay maybe I
won't but I want a rook that's kind of
annoying let's do this
okay he has a lot of pawns but they're
all gonna fall good game
hello Kiyomi double X slam hello - char
on Achatz what's up Oh
35th place getting my streak back Wow
130 points I have 50 points okay I've
only been playing the tournament for
like half hours so um 50 points every
half hour then should be able to fight
back okay it's gonna be a perk Queen 85
this is a decent idea because he wants
to play e5 I'll still Castle queenside
and King d1 maybe h4 oh maybe he'll
Castle queenside maybe not Bishop a6
okay I get some initiative like all
these moves come with tempo oh it was a
good move because he's frightening night
c4 but I have some pressure maybe this
move there's a lot of pressure here and
this might just be winning cuz he has no
counter play on the Queen side he has no
man no source of counter play
yeah ex villager you can give a timeout
if it's necessary it's hard for me to
control the chat let's do a timeout or
dad whatever floats your boat let me
focus here oh you want stop like oh
that's what free nights ok it's gonna
say he wanted to play queen bee for good
try ok 26th place got my streak back
trying to get my rating back fee day 15
what country unknown a3 is best met with
g6 because before Bishop g7 comes with
tempo I don't know what to do here maybe
I actually told what to do here let's
just play normally play some dragon
setup yeah this can't be bad I don't
think why am I still using a trackpad
because I got a mouse and I was slow
with the mouse and it's gonna take a
while before I become fast with the
mouse so I'm drinking tea spiced chai
black tea what is the structure let's do
this I'll probably play c4 at some
points but now my knight has a happy
place rook c8 well I'm moving really
slowly
let's move faster let's take with
Knights yeah cuz t4 is a nice square and
this bishops so bad that's a free bishop
mm-hmm that's a free rook maybe not
entirely free but free enough take all
those pawns defend that pawn take that
take that everything is free um to do
here
everything's defended now now I can
start pushing them baby like B 4 B 3 B -
okay let's defend that he keeps poking
at me I have to watch out for the time
okay we'll trade Queens oh my gosh
trackpad work okay
this is stressful so I got a mouse
my beautiful mouse is right here I know
if people can see this it's a log of
tech Logitech cost like $50.00 I'm in
the process of trying to learn how to
use it but if I'm doing any competitive
bullet I'm still faster with the
trackpad so it's going to take like a
little bit of time somewhat of a
learning curve go fast ski go fack see
I'll play E for this game play my
favorite opening d3 some kind of Grand
Prix type thing is that a free pawn that
looks like a free pawn and now the
structure is just really bad for black
and I can continue normally II five
doesn't quite work I'm gonna go I'll go
kind of all out for a kingside assault
if he lets me first I have to defend
stuff maybe b3 Wow he's being annoying
yeah it's gonna take a while before I
can start attacking slowly but surely
that's a pain
whoa he takes and attacks my queen I
didn't see that this should still be
okay for whites
I have many pawns for the exchange and I
have the G file now which maybe can be
used mmm what to do
maybe this I wanted to trade off the
Bishop to weaken his dark swears I don't
know if it accomplishes that much oh I
had asked for
maybe he'll miss f4 again no he didn't
this is uncomfortable
I would love a queen trade okay
now I'm happy he could win pawns or not
cuz I have a lot of pawns now and
everything's defended I just have to
move fast
okay he was about to meet me there thank
God I saw it I'm still in trouble with
time free moving a bot Wow what's going
on
he's moving faster than me still but not
anymore okay please flag okay there we
go
whoa ten wait I can't even read that
number
there's too many zeros to my eyesight is
bad it's at ten thousand bits one two
three four
Wow thank you coy TV I appreciate that
that's a lot of bits that's like the
biggest cheer ever thank you so much
well now okay I still have to focus what
does this move d6 20,000 wait do I miss
something else I'm so confused
check stream labs and a little bit okay
this is just a hedgehog openings like
this you have to play really quickly
because it's gonna be a very long game
he's gonna play before yeah
my rickshaw have been on Yeats there's
this one classic maneuver Bishop d8
Bishop c7 we each kind of do our own
thing until the positions gonna get
really messy soon because I'm going to
push my H pawn all the way to h3 or
maybe play Knight f4 first d5 explosive
I don't know what's going on here he
wants to win that pawn when I play h3
this Bishop becomes happier because
x-ray vision and then maybe this oh he
won the pond and he's attacking my rook
a scythe looks really weakening this is
bad
cuz now my King's weak but his Kings
also slightly suspicious I don't know
what's going on here I just have to play
quickly Queen b7 at some point maybe
queen c6 please take my wreck please
take my rook cuz then I win this no he
took that
okay well Queen and Knight first Queen
and Bishop I'll trade he's up to pawns
oh shoot my Knights trapped that's bad
this is really bad
no he mated me out
what is going on okay Stream labs login
what did I miss
back to tournament this is taking a
while to load kawaii TV gifted a tier 1
sub to acts villager Wow
so generous 5000 bits to another 5000
bits is that twenty thousand bits
rainbows guy a hundred bits well thank
you rainbow sky but thank you koi TV
yeah I should stream more often
especially at this time something you're
awake
okay what is this opening it's like some
Slav type thing where I just push all my
pawns
I think I'm content with this like
before coming maybe b4 b5 just like some
positional plans
you can't stop be 5 because there's a
tin and then let's take that and then
another b4 yeah I've had this situation
a lot where like he wants to play rook
b8 but he can't play rugby 8 oh he wants
to play e5 let's do this
he still oh he could play rook b8 there
okay this is a fight what to do
I mean I like White's position this
block has weaknesses maybe I just win
the a pawn yeah I'll take that
oh oh he wins H pawn ouch oh this is
getting messy come around attacking from
the rear all the emotes Wow an elastic
hold
okay he's moving a bit too slowly it
looks like I can just take everything he
can't touch my pawns because they're all
on dark squares I can dance around with
my Knights oh I can't take that bishop
like his King can't get in and my Kings
coming in again I'm tagged I'm attacking
from the rear I'll win this e6 pawn
maybe the final problem yeah I mean
chess is not an easy game at all uh what
is this opening H for this is like the
crew 64 opening where H 4 is probably a
useful move maybe 9 H 5 and now I'm
hitting this the only way to defend that
pawn is G 3 but then he loses he 5 oh he
is G 4 and I lose a piece but he didn't
see it that's nice I'm a king e7 o
Bishop f4 Intermezzo and I take
I'll get the Knight to f4 he's gonna
double up in the D file or not let's try
that pair of rooks and blacks just up
upon here uh-oh he's getting counter
play what do I do
whoa King c8 slight
comfortable I'm still up upon rookie
eights coming if we trade rooks its
winning four lakh Oh tears check home I
really just want to trade rooks gonna
play h5 it's a positional move now I
probably win both his age pawns he's
gonna win some Queen side pawns and now
it's gonna be a pond race but I think
I'm faster pretty sure I'm faster yeah
that pawn was pretty fast nice
okay good game 17th place trying to make
it into the top 10 of 68 points Wow
over an hour left I'm trying to stay
focused
wait 30,000 I thought it was 20,000 my
gosh well thank you koi TV thank you
everyone for watching very grateful I
don't usually do pool it streams because
they're not as instructive but I mean I
have to do them once in a while is he
trying he's trying to play a hippo the
best strategy against a hippo is just to
push pawns create weaknesses this is a
weakness ooh I really want to take I'm
not going to calculate it let's just
take everything this is looking really
really fun d6 is attacked I could have
taken his rook maybe but yeah let's take
his Knight and then take on d6 I don't
want to
take the rook again but I will hey I
haven't lost upon oh he wants to wants
to take on e4 Wow
25 I mean uh oh he's winning pawns but
we'll trade Queens what's the material
situation seven points life I have three
pawns on the rook for a knight in Bishop
which that's a pretty good material in
balance because pawns are easy to push
well that was a tricky move but now I'm
attacking the Knights he could be brave
and come in there whoa okay let's open
this file up I mean the minor pieces are
slightly annoying think I can take their
g5 I just have to move quickly
okay tactics more tactics more tactics
that's so nice mates okay
good game 14th place mmm I am I don't
want to hurt myself for not seeing that
name I'm not gonna shoot I beserk I'll
beserk let's show off some hyperbolic
skills I'm really slow with hyper
bullets deserting was probably not a
good idea but at least I'm in a
structure which I'm somewhat comfortable
with I play this many many times before
that's a bishop trap oh but he's being
tricky wow he's being very tricky I
didn't want to take that what is he
doing stop it
nope nope
oh no I hung Maiden one out that was
unfortunate yeah tapas urk next time I'm
just taking the tile odds Kovalchuk 94
yeah let's not get on tilt g6 let's play
this h4 h5 line if he lets me move each
six keep marching that pond this is
actually annoying for black because this
bishop can't develop normally this pond
is gonna forever be defended that was
slightly sneaky by him so he castles
Queen side not a bad plan this is a
really weird position
I think I'm happy because this bishop is
sad mmm f6 was a really good move
actually what do I do
I guess we could trade everything I'll
trade Queens
oh I lose f2 but now I'm attacking this
Bishop let's defend f2 I have to move
much quicker positional
a four undermine the pawn structure well
what is he doing take that this is
really crazy now I'll take that take
that I think we're just trading a lot of
things I'll play 94 mm and see for ya
I've to defend the night okay I think
I'm moving quickly enough
oh no I hung a ruck no please don't win
please don't win yes I was stressful
that was really stressful need to save
money for a session with Eric yeah if
you want if you want a lesson just
message me anytime okay I'm playing this
guy again I think I played the same
opening last time except he's playing
differently no this is a nice line for a
bullet because white gets some early
pressure played Bishop h4 Castle
queenside efore this is d6 where it's
all mine for going for a5 some pin
action I've really bad at drawing arrows
what's going on here let's just develop
Bishop b3 the problem is
nights are kind of stuck to each other
um okay now I can take and take
Oh his knight was hanging loops let's
play h4 [ __ ] there feel like I'm playing
this in a somewhat messy fashion but it
should still be good for white I guess
it's just a really messy position rook
d2 should win something maybe not
okay now I'm winning something or am I
Ricky one that's supposed to trade okay
up a piece he's still kind of attacking
me I should have taken on d5 first this
should be enough to win let go for meat
oh that's not quite meat woo now it's
mate okay if you take side rook I fate
if he doesn't take I forgot seven Bishop
g7 if he lets me please let me ah what
is this
oops no how did I let that slip okay
it's so messy okay not the best
technique there but now I kinda streak
I'm still trying to break 2500 it's not
the easiest task wow it's really hard to
keep up with the chat we're going to
schedule another session sure uh Queen
h3 more okay yeah let's talk afterwards
let me stay focused with bullets oh
that's a free night
people are generous I'm going to go for
the quick kill maybe not
I wanted to play an IG for okay still
trying trying to play aggressively 95
once I can feel Keller the Bishop to be
seven life will be good nine of five
some nice night
this is queen doing there okay finally
all feeling kind of the bishop now I
just have to get rid of this pawn
maybe I'll just trade Queens up a piece
again this is not the cleanest
conversion but oh wow
this is really not clean I'm losing can
i Castle I can't even Castle am I gonna
lose this I might actually lose this
this is really unfortunate ouch
I'm losing this this is really really
sad also I can like perpetual him
somehow or confuse him long enough until
he Flags know
it was a time scramble yeah that was
that was completely unacceptable he hung
a night unlike moved three to not win
that it's so sad
okay 17th place I'm still trying to
break into the top ten it's not the
easiest task but I'm trying for aeneas
okay I'll play a London c5 III oh he's
playing tricky stuff this is actually
kind of a true London usually I like to
avoid these structures but okay it's
playable
oh wait wait what
Bishop a6 was uh not defended I don't
know what made me think a six was
defended maybe I thought my Queen was
somehow defending because it's such a
common idea okay I have to move quicker
I'm gonna attack e6
it's a decent move but it gets hits
hopefully get the night time for ya
attacking more things I'll stick my
knight in g6 not sure if it's doing
anything there but it looks pretty
maybe Queen a6 next whoa take take take
okay do it like that
Queen d3 ah okay my knight is actually
completely useless on g6 oh maybe now I
can trade
oh I didn't want to play 9h8 settling
the Knights okay gonna still try it here
maybe I can meet him just my king and
rook I might actually be winning this
okay that kind of made up for last game
just down down a piece about position
but he was too slow Chesky - I think
Chesky was streaming earlier
oh by hell elastic hold sorry you have
to go okay we're gonna try and play a
bit more solidly in this game playing
one of my favorite variations this is
known as the Ray Robson variation named
after the famous American GM who's a
good friend of mine uh b5 I think is
possible a4 on passant a6 ooh he won the
pawn back that was a good move I want to
lose another pawn let's play Queen a5
I mean it's equal material slight
imbalance hopefully it's easier to play
for a black I just pushed this pawn and
I went at night that's nice wait elastic
hold so he had to go right but he's
still here you can't turn away am I
losing that pawn I might be losing the
pawn I'm gonna sack my queen oh maybe
not okay I'll win the D pawn whoa I
can't win the D pawn oh oh wait this is
bad
okay he had a 5:00 somewhere there I
think now it's still good up on time and
a combination of night and queen is
pretty deadly okay we'll just trade so
slightly annoying position to win okay
one second left
oh wow koi TV gifted a sub to Kiyomi H
Wow such generosity
yeah Kiyomi was probably one of like the
first-ever viewers to my stream I think
at least within the first week of
streaming okay I'm playing feat a 15
again
oh he plays this weird line let's play
d5 this time not sure 55 a move but he
can't play b4 cuz Queen e5 check play
Queen D eights b6 is probably not a
great move
I don't know what's going on here all I
know is black is very much behind
development but maybe not anymore to do
take take okay let's play rook c8 I'm
just gonna go
the attack this is probably very unsound
but it looks fun you can't take the
night because rook h8 mate but II six is
kind of weak hmm what to do g5
I know if g5 does anything but it looks
interesting
oh I just lost two nights oh he's a good
player and I'm severely the long time
this is a terrible game and he is 94 oh
gosh
Queen up to maybe Oh oops oops wait
let's sack everything and hopefully he
still needs me nevermind oh that was
difficult I got to what's the right word
I was trying to create too much of a
masterpiece and it's severely backfired
well now I'm pretty far away from 2500
but maybe by the end of the tournament
hello to Chernobyl pp oh wait the PPS
are silent I remember that
hello anyway thanks for coming back to
watch so if he wins e5 I win b7 if he
doesn't take you 5 I have a nice bunch
of pawns in the center this is a nice
diamond formation not sure if it has any
significance but looks nice queen g6
that's a whole
I think the planets upon storm like g4
f5 okay this is looking pretty fun do I
do here just keep taking pawns hmm wait
a minute where's my mates oh there's me
took a long time I was looking like how
do I get the rope to a for a bit just
made in one only one Korean chest
streamer okay chest student in 22 good
luck
gonna play a Kings Indian attack it
looks like yeah this is my pet line like
most people have their pawns on c5 when
they play this sort of setup but I like
to keep the pawn on c7 because g6 is not
a weakness in this line hmm looks it
looks actually kind of passive for luck
wow he wants to kill me I don't think
that works like if he could teleport his
Queen to g7 it would work or in bug
house it would be a great move but I'll
put my bishop on f8 and then like what
is he doing maybe 95 so I hang a piece
that hangs a piece okay let's trade in
Queenie eights idea for updates I mean
he has like
a bunch of things staring at the
kingside but I don't think he can break
through and probably Queen e8 was
important to the Fen g6 another time
otherwise you would sack okay let's
counter-attack
I should see five check take just trade
everything I mean black is up a piece
check ooh that's some nice mates from
corner to corner
okay um 12th place very close to top ten
VIN VIN 2020 in the chat shout-out to
Patrick JMT suggesting Queen a5 not sure
when that moment was when I could have
played Queen a5 let's play Annie for
opening this game - I do here g3 and
we'll play like some close Sicilian or I
like this might h3 move because it
facilitates f5 and then tonight f2 and G
for some classic pawn storm action here
he's that was a good move because I
basically had to play h5 my pawns form
kind of came to uh whoa I just hung a
queen and a knight but he he didn't see
Knight a key - that's nice lacy for okay
this reminds me of checkers just all the
pawns on light squares oh wow
well my bishop is pretty depressed here
oh and I can't actually play g5
well let's switch everything over to the
Queen side will trade Queens okay that
was a blunder I mean I'm up a bishop but
my bishop is still pretty ineffective
but
this should be winning as I'm gonna
break through with b4 if somehow like I
played b5 and he played a five I think
it's just a draw but my plan would be to
play a5 and open at least one file so
11th place 92 points I don't think I'm
gonna have any fight for first place but
maybe top 5 yeah definitely top five
let's try and break into the top 5 night
31 good luck ok cue Wiens gambit
declined this is my pet line a 6 a 4 is
a playable move it should be 7 and will
go for these very typical Queens gambit
declined plans except I just dropped a
pond that's so sad yeah I'm losing my
sharpness slightly unfortunate but ok
let's try and come back here I think I
went up on back I'll go first on some
pressure somehow maybe Queen d7 cuz now
there's this pin and I can perhaps
exploit the pin I guess he has Queen B
to solving all of his problems oh no am
I losing a pawn I think I'm losing g7
that's really sad wait I'm not losing g7
cuz I take on b4 but then he takes on
each 6 chess is so complicated so it's
an interesting position because the
amount of pawns don't necessarily matter
it's all about passed pawns
I can't trade Queens unfortunately let's
do this b5 oh no he had Queen h8 but he
missed it missed nice
that's the e5 and then this uh I didn't
want to do that
oops okay I just have to move fast and
flag him okay that's a free queen thank
you that was messy I mean he could have
easily won at various moments there if
especially if he found Queen h8 just
winning the Queen okay I try and keep
the streak I should be able to beat this
guy in eight to one lifetime score it's
my favorite opening Grand Prix let's not
trade Queens
go for a 5 IG 5 this is not working out
the way I wanted it to uh yeah that's
really bad what just happened
I'm just losing a piece but I play
tonight that's right he would take and
attack my queen with his bishop mmm this
is yeah this is not what I wanted so
we're trading everything I'm just down a
piece but maybe there's hope I always
need some hope let's play rook F 2 so
I'll win d6 rook f2 prevented rookie to
some lines mmm
let's do this rookie - coming maybe
there's comp there is comp I'm winning a
piece back nice yeah we'll trade all of
his pawns are isolated yeah this is
really nice explai for I just need to
move slightly quicker maybe we can trade
rooks mm-hmm okay
there we go there we go
okay back to tournaments hello to excise
sparks I think exercise sparks has been
here for a while I just forgot to say
hello
someone fluffy panda hello okay hey top
ten hundred points
$24.99 okay this is a game where I'm
going to try and break 2500 I've never
lost to this guy let's play Bishop g5 I
have three mm-hmm interesting this is
gonna get slightly complex
she takes there ya go win b2 I can't
play there should be five check so you
would have the eventual queen a5 not
sure what's going on here I think I'm
down upon now let's play Bishop b5 and
actually let's just take yeah this is
really confusing cuz how do I win the
b-pawn have to play like at 4500 maybe I
could have taken ooh do like ah that
doesn't work let's play this Oh II 5 was
a good move because if he takes my rook
I take the bishop with check but I
didn't see that
taketake okay I have to play this this
is getting really messy 5 in the end
he's getting comp I have to stop talking
play good moves I'm gonna sack
oh he's gonna beat me no yeah that was
kind of an opening going wrong I thought
I had some tactic there to come back
that e5 moved it just didn't work and
I'm not breaking 2500 and I'm not
deserting this guy because he beat me
last time I'm gladly taking the time
odds I just have to make sure I beat him
this game so I would be embarrassing to
lose to him if he berserks me let's play
this line and try and confuse him I just
want to make him think I don't have
Bishop a6 what do i do check their play
Bishop here and then s5 no let's Castle
queenside then s5 if I have the time
oh my gosh okay that's made in one
at first I thought II five was like a
good move but yeah it just ended the
game
okay southern place I mean to break into
the top five I need like 18 more points
need to catch up to baron g6 so many
people playing g6 today let's put the
knight on g5
hmmm I think I can take there's probably
some come for black but hopefully it's
not too much so I'll go for F 3 and then
Castle White's up upon
you
oh he wants to somehow meet me on b2 but
if you ever plays before I play Knight
at four and I think it's safe now I go
for f5 hmm have to do some rearranging
that was a good move always play King b1
okay this is getting very messy not sure
what's going on I think I can take that
my Knights completely how to play I just
want to open the H file there we go and
attack the bishop hey it's over
so you can't stop Queen take h6 okay
nice game seven place another iron okay
let's take this seriously he's playing
really quickly and I don't mind this
position okay we can trade and slightly
better for whites that's a good move
whoa I was unexpected can I just take
that and Bishop here Oh Queen h7 coming
okay I have to be very careful very
careful
he has Bishop e6 coming too no I'm just
getting smash this game this is at least
pg-13 for all the chill
and watching please cover your eyes no
okay I'm just gonna resign sorry for the
underage viewers there mm it's gonna
play a scandi now it's like a good what
do we call this a good French a good
Carol calm happy Bishop what to do there
should be seven and g5g for plans whoa
everyone's sacking today not sure if
that was a Sakura blunder probably just
a bad sack okay I'm gonna bring the King
to g7 he's gonna win g5 oops but I'm
still up a piece okay at least I'm
finding happy places for the Knights
Queen B seven and Roxy eight maybe this
move g2 is kind of a target oh this is
funny he can't take either night because
Queen g2 he's just stuck I'm just gonna
play waiting moves and make him think uh
or not waits what's going on I'm gonna
leave my nights where they are and check
where's the mates where is the mate wait
what am I losing this
oh my gosh no how am i losing this oh
it's stalemate oh my gosh I saved it
point four seconds left and he still
mated me where was my maid in that
position like my night two nights and
queen with his lone king that's like I
mean how much better can it get but the
nights are so clumsy I mean I could play
no King each six doesn't work
hello Savannah oh is it just losing four
black I'm gonna screenshot this position
and then take a look at it later
I'm just gonna save the link to paste
okay moving on still fighting for top
five currently in eighth place
Baron keeps losing which is good I'll
play a London Oh see four okay I don't
know what we call the setup light just
Castle queenside
but it's a fun kind of just system to
play just Castle queenside and then go
all out on the kingside maybe g5 not
gonna calculate and then II for I have
the open G file some attacking ideas at
four is week five comes oh I can't take
on you for cuz Bishop f5 let's do it
anyway he's gonna play Bishop at five
and I'll win both his bishops and maybe
there's some mating idea or just maybe
not I was probably a bad decision
but as I say bad decisions lead to
better stories and to better checkmates
9 f6 unstoppable wow that really worked
out I'll meet him on h8 can pre move
next to moves that was nice after this
tournament can we look at that Knight
Queen situation yes but please remind me
because I'm guaranteed to forget this
guy's buzzer King was working 101 living
up to his name what do I do here I guess
I take and I'm up upon oops
no I meant to play Bishop c7 okay at
least I'm up a lot of time I'll win the
d6 pawn okay you sacking OOP don't want
to play move e5
yeah I'm just gonna try and flag this
guy or maybe made him
I made him or make a queen at least oops
okay yeah I have to flag him hmm
oh I didn't see that oh this is slightly
scary but he's three seconds left but
I'm running long time too
I'd better not lose this I have two
queens okay
that was somewhat concerning me close
but the win is a win still in eighth
place it's gonna be very hard to break
into the top five but I'm playing Baron
s/m interesting line in 95 here's a
decent move and then f4 yeah this is
probably a fine setup
gonna go for this g4 break oh no it's
not a break I'll do it anyway and my
bishop probably wants to be somewhere
else
um but what to do Queen d2 it's slightly
uncomfortable to defend Bishop II one I
guess kind of necessary and I'm gonna
try and get some kingside activity like
f5 f5 f6 always play off 6g 5h4 I'm just
gonna keep pushing hmm I don't want to
play h6 oh but what do I do
Queen h2 and I'll win the deep on this
is scary my bishops still doing nothing
and I'm low on time oops and I hung a
queen that's really sad no okay there we
go oh my gosh my trackpad just stopped
working
oh my gosh oh that's so unfortunate and
that was a guy who I'm fighting for or
fighting against I'm playing another
strong player who's also streaming
what to do what is this line F for let's
play a 6 B 5 I'm just gonna like storm
everything on the queenside oops I hung
up on I forgot about the pin yeah I
think I've had a bit too much bullet
today I'm starting to see less and less
is the video quality low I'm sorry about
that
I could try and yeah I can try and
reduce it does that involve changing the
bit rate or does that involve doing
something else or maybe is it your
Internet's hopefully it's your internet
and not my internet this is really
uncomfortable let's do this
oh man okay
I'm sacking your nights just gotta play
quick
hmm check and oh man no he won something
please tell me please tell me me he's
not still meeting me that's so
unfortunate
it's not about 60fps let me check
settings output oh the video bitrate is
1200 can I just boost it to like I
should boost it to 2000 right let me
know like if is 1200 and okay pay rates
I think that was from something earlier
I'll boost its like 1600 Roger 2017
thanks for the follow back to tournament
I still don't like entirely understand
the settings oh maybe I can change the
FPS it says 48 fps at the bottom dropped
frame 0% that's probably a good sign ok
let's get back on a winning streak I'm
gonna play Grand Prix against this
bf5 oh that's a free pond that's two
free ponds I have to restart the stream
Oh
so complicated okay let's destroy this
guy quickly
let's take there and then probably even
queen h5 I don't take on each six
immediately because now I take on h6 and
I'm threatening mates this is made in
three I think
one two oh it's me then okay you could
have played King f6 King g5 but there
was definitely made somewhere there
okay hogie 2315 I like this position
this is like a good version of night h4
interesting move yeah it's like a London
but he wasted a tempo playing Bishop
chief g5 and then Bishop f4 now I
couldn't play Bishop outside back and
wouldn't the b-pawn mm-hmm he just got
some counter play Wow he's getting a lot
of counter play this is scary what's
going on g6 maybe
yeah I'm in the castle sack the hsx pawn
and then plate rook the eights
wait a minute this is me Queen take p1
that's nice yeah I'll play around with
the settings after the stream I think
sometimes it can depend on the internet
too like some days Internet's just
slower than others oh I'm playing a
steno chess whose video I was actually
watching last night's I was watching his
commentary from the last titled arena
titled arena events
we're going into a lion which I've
actually studied pretty extensively but
now I forget what to do I guess Bishop
Bishop t2 and there's some kind of
long-term comp they're supposed to be
long-term comp um but he's playing
really quickly this guys are really good
commentator like he's really good at
commentating like one minute um - this
oh I'm just down oh never mind I win the
pawn deck let's do this he's playing
quicker than me but at least I have some
fights Oh Bishop f6 coming he's gonna
see it - no don't see Bishop f6 he saw
it
okay I'm winning the C pawn thanks for
the follow crunch tooth oh [ __ ] I can't
play rook I have to do that maybe it's
not too bad cuz I'll win ce6 and it's a
position he's winning that
oh he wins more stuff this is so sad
it's painful to be down a piece no okay
good player well now I guess the goal is
to stay within the top ten there's a lot
of good players here about the supreme
quality it's possible issue stream
screen resolution I don't think I've
ever changed a screen resolution I mean
look look at how this stream looks this
guy wants to be Zurich let's bezerk him
okay I have to play quickly this is
already a good position for white Bishop
a6 no okay he should've played Bishop a6
okay we're in some interesting endgame
my nights gonna be such a good piece on
d4 you can't really touch anything
I guess Bishop's just useless oh never
mind
you wanna pawn uh-oh my King's kind of
stuck oh never mind
it's a weird position lots of dancing
around there we go
okay it's a lot of chess and I'm out of
tea it's a bit unfortunate oh I'm
playing a stunt at chess
okay let's take this a bit more
seriously I'm gonna play for this game
I'll play a carro con and we'll try and
meet him ah he saw it okay h3 I guess
hmm my structure isn't that great but I
do have two bishops what do I do here
mm I have to accept even worse pawn
structure this is sad this is pretty sad
[Music]
cuz I have no play I have to keep
defending things and he's winning at
least upon or not he's just torturing me
though okay we can trade
ouch ouch okay he came and he's good
oh is it laggy or okay I can reduce a
bit rate back to 1200 it shouldn't be
laggy but maybe like okay I have to look
at how uh the bitrate affects the lag
1200 back okay
I think there's there is supposed to be
a way where I like give users ability to
like change what quality they're
watching it but maybe that requires
partnership status not entirely sure
oh the moves in the game yeah how do I
fix that because I know like it doesn't
it's not as smooth as like other other
streams I'm not sure how to fix that
okay we're playing another Ray Robson
variation castle castle b5 so last time
I hung up on somehow but I figure out
how oh he played rook b8 last time a
rook b1 and then I take C for your black
is holding on Salaam the peace movements
are very smooth on my screen yeah oh my
gosh I hung about papaw in the same way
as last time okay you focus
he's winning he's maybe winning the fun
but I have counterplay bouquet one's a
serious threat also rook 8 - okay this
is looking better take that Oh Queen
eight one but then Queen f6 hmm Oh Queen
they won Queen take F - mm-hmm Oh
oh that's not good take this is really
bad
no he has made in one but he didn't see
it yes he had made in one foot taken f6
uh I can't draw arrows okay Chesky also
watching okay yeah that was close
I'm in 10th place is this guy's not
gonna desert me because he bezerk last
time and I didn't desert back I have one
pretty easily
okay we'll play a smith mora or not
let's play e5 tricky move am I already
in trouble I'm in big trouble already
oops okay I lose the pawn back hopefully
I don't lose too much more this is
looking really bad but somehow lack
surviving
and he's being slightly reckless but in
my payoff I don't know
oh no it's paying off
ouch ouch
this is physically painful oh okay
resign
still in 10th place earlier in the
tournament I was like on a good streak
and now I just continued to lose games
and it's been a while since I've been on
any sort of streak I'm playing buzzer
King all the circum back oh my gosh okay
there's a fine line between moving
quickly and I'm playing good moves I'm
down a piece but position is okay well
now the positions getting really crazy
it's going to say the position was
pretty closed so I meant to play rock h1
okay now I should be winning somehow
maybe not
okay when your birthday my birth isn't
like another five to six months it was
recently my half birthday
that's pretty insignificant
okay playing Ronnie 30 have another
Queens gambit declined I have some
Carlsbad structure oh he wants to be
aggressive oh gee for a very sharp
position I think you forgot my rooks on
a six can just take everything and then
what to do maybe Queen e4 and trade
contrite Queens
so backs up upon that more importantly
up a ton of time interesting
you
winning one of his pawns that was
probably a bad idea because now I have
to be careful about cell matrix never
mind I was a good idea ax villager is
right do I have a schedule for my my my
streams we type in schedule
wait is moobot not working there should
be a schedule command oh I thought there
is a schedule command you just have to
go to like my website and then go to
schedule but this we schedule is in the
making because this week I have like a
different different schedule of things
okay another positional game let's not
get forked that was maybe a free pawn
except
extra pawn doesn't mean too much I'm
gonna expand on the kingside he's gonna
play knight c6 that's a really annoying
square for the knight because these
pawns are pretty weak in the long term
so let's try and get that night out of
there and then target c6 actually I
think White's winning I'm upon on c6
how does he defend yep let's play a
fancy move zagging the exchange but
there's no open files so his rooks can't
really penetrate and I have a really
nice time advantage I can just dance
around and maybe walk my King in
okay nice game it's still in 10th place
man anyone like right behind me
127 No
so I'll safely make it to the top 10
it's a question of if I can get more
more points ok I'm playing a Ben Oni for
some reason I don't usually play the
Benoni
but I think it's an underrated opening
lots of dynamic interesting ideas which
happened from these positions the one
downside black is kind of low on space
but it's kind of a counterpunching
opening like Queen h4 I'll just start
sacking everything and hopefully it
leaves some mates oh he didn't take on
h3
he wants to play rugby eights I can't
ignore that mm-hmm I didn't see that
move
okay I'm gonna forget about my Queen
side pieces and just go for the kill and
this should be good
because I'm winning this or this oh also
I'm threatening rook h5 which is just
game over am I gonna play more bullet
after this probably not but there is FXI
sparks is still around I do want to look
at that one position like the craziest
position I had this whole this whole
tournament where like I should have been
winning but if I wasn't winning and
there's something terribly wrong with
the universe let's suppose work this guy
try and get the bonus points okay I'm
gonna push the pawn and push more pawns
I'm just gonna keep pushing pawns until
I run out of pawn moves OOP
okay keep keep moving pawns now I've run
out its castle
it's a weird position oh he won't see
bishop a scythe yeah and his knight gets
trapped I think somehow maybe not number
9 yeah let's do this
oh I wanted to play a bishop a for mates
okay
still number nine I really want to pass
this guy the only other streamer from
Russia
privyet I'm only gonna have like one
more game if I win the last game I'll
pass him because he's not on the streak
so hopefully I'll play someone be the
bowl yeah okay I just have to make sure
this game counts for the tournaments so
it's a London
I try and play aggressively
I lost upon also just trying to play
quickly too
and because I want to make sure this
game counts for the tournament but at
this point it's it might not count yeah
I think it is fine I just have to focus
on not losing oh wait this is bad this
is really really bad
do we have to trade everything I have a
five key move yeah the tournament's over
sadly this is bad I'm trying win
something here no he can take on a -
that's so sad but is he gonna flag maybe
he'll flag okay he fight
not the best finish I did not end the
tournament above 2500 congratulations to
the one and only okay good because he
won the tournament I'll try and say his
name I might hurt myself in doing so
Nikolai Jurgis Jorgensen Nikolai
Jorgensen congratulations whoo I think
you beat me a couple of times at least
one time that was a draw because he
flagged and I only had a king so not his
real name yeah I would cry if that was
my real name so what I wanted to do was
go told that one game that I played oh
you're g'sten oh that J is not
pronounced like a J okay number twenty
who is number twenty
why is it not working I'm clicking I'm
still confused am I connected I think
I'm connected refresh there we go that
was weird
Oh number twenty congratulations VIN VIN
not bad okay what I wanted to do cuz I
saved the screenshots I didn't say is
the name of my opponent what game was
that oh that was a game I flagged I
flagged the guy like a losing position
let's see if I can find it wasn't this
one no not that one
yeah oh no there was this one where he
stalemated me yeah this is the one game
like I was really really curious about
it
okay me saying click harder yeah I think
I think it was just like some bug with
leech s I don't think there was
something wrong with my computer um yeah
let's go back to yeah I'm sorry Chesky
Chesky to who should not have lost to me
in either game well that's life
okay so this game was pretty
entertaining we got to this position
where if he takes this night or if he
takes this night
there's queen g2 mates so I was really
happy I thought I was gonna win easily
and then he played king h2 and I had
wait can we go to houses for yeah how
much time do they have this window
bigger wait why is it not showing the
time I have to make it much bigger well
then that messed up the layout let me
move this back I'll have to make it
smaller is that the time is like on the
very edge there we go
okay hopefully that's not too small so I
had 20 seconds 20 seconds at this point
and I thought he was gonna run out of
moves
but then he played King g3 and I play
tonight G - I was happy my Knights
defend each other and Queen f3 I didn't
want to trade Queens of course and then
you played Queen b7 which was a terrible
if I could just take his queen I have 14
seconds left but I was so focused on
playing Queen e1 like even before he
moved his Queen like I probably was
hovering over like getting ready to play
Queen Queen e1 I just assumed it would
be mate and then he plays King H - wait
how do I turn off the engine computer
now so
disable there we go okay and then this
was a key position where yeah the
analysis graph is showing weight stuff I
mean I thought there should be a win
because like okay then the king is just
alone with my two knights and my queen
but waits for anything made into and the
question is can black do anything to
survive I guess it's an issue when we're
talking about survival because there's
no way to the fend of seven I played the
only move I saw and I Teflon I don't
think there's any other candidate move
here
does my takes e4 pawn to g4 doesn't seem
to lead to much there's also King h6
but King h6 leads tonight take out of
seven with force mate okay so I played
nine f1 and then I went back oh no wait
a minute
I had Queen h1 I think I realized this
in the game too I realized it after I
played Queen f1 the Queen h1 is just
winning the Queen wait so if White has
to play Y has to play King h2 here and
is there mate
Queen f2 where is mate I mean maybe I
could just take an f4 know taking on f4
leads to night 86 king h2 is it just a
draw anyone saying stuff in the chat 9 f
193 wait Knight f1 I don't understand it
will point not have fun maybe he met
Knight f1 Knight e3 which is what I
played
Oh Tom Miller is back Tom Lehrer was the
first commenter who commented on time
after like one minute of the stream I
don't see a win here for a black I think
it's just a draw unless I'm missing
something simple oh wait there's queenie
one it's a candidate move
queenie one king h2 night f1 for
thinking g2 this is all for singing but
now black runs out of checks I mean the
Queen night combination usually is very
strong that in this case I guess it's
somewhat clumsy in terms of like
continuing the forcing moves yeah I
don't see anything that's crazy
so I guess my conclusion is that this is
just a draw a stock fish just to drop Oh
Queen take ya Queen jp-7 obviously good
Queen e1 draw that's insane
it's like if we compare this to real
life it's like a toddler who walks down
like a dark alley in the middle of the
night and like three thugs approached
the toddler but the toddler is like
completely safe just some sort of like
force field around the around the king
that's insane okay I think I'm gonna end
it there oh shout out to everyone who
like followed and donated shout out
again to koi TV who like gifted subs and
like cheered what did he cheer he
cheered like a total of thirty thousand
bits that's incredible
any other follows oh yeah okay so here's
the follows he's all happened over 20
minutes ago like had a flam crunch tooth
meatus Maxon yeesh I swallow
Komi - thank you everyone I'm actually
going to be back tomorrow there's a
title tuesday event on chess calm I was
planning to stream the last title
Tuesday but they ended up canceling it
so hopefully they don't cancel
tomorrow's event and then I will
probably put out this forum scheduled
for later on in the week are you serious
no chess is raining with a party of 27
just as I'm about to end the stream well
you know what this means
wait Drive any challenges I don't have
any challenges I mean I have a life and
I don't want to like continue just
streaming and like not do anything today
my dog needs a walk I have to find
another streamer to raid it says no joke
is still streaming but I guess he just
ended that's a brilliant profile picture
oh wow crew 64 just messaged me let me
say you
start a stream I'm streaming now I need
someone to read okay um Wow he's
finished his stream no joke
okay well I'll play someone I don't want
to play a long game uh wait is there
anyone else streaming I honestly don't
know these people I know one of them
streams in Russian okay let's play one
game I'll play a fan I don't wanna play
standard unfortunately it's all I'll
play I'll play don't read this I don't
think I've stayed in before a good luck
I'm gonna play the Budapest and I'll try
and be a bit more chat focused whoa that
line up looks or the layout looks
terrible right now can i enlarge this
sorry yeah this should be better I have
a slight OCD there we go okay I'm gonna
play Bishop c5 I'll have the chat open
oh I just ran it although I fell for the
trap yeah I'm not gonna say his name
again
hopefully that's the only trap I fall
for it's this guy so this is another
like fun variation for blitz
Kru 64 you need to start now uh castle
and rookie eights for anyone who doesn't
know this line there's a really fun kind
of clever idea
Wow infinite flash chess was hosting me
well thank you infinite flash chess but
about this position there's a really
cool idea rook a six rook h6 or of g6
which I've played many times before but
against people who haven't encountered
this it can be pretty shocking this
doesn't happen in too many other opening
so I'm gonna play Bishop a7i Bishop f8
probably Bishop f8 and once the row
comes to h6 I can play Queen h4 d 6
ideally made him on h2 infinite flash
chest yeah I'm having a good day I slept
in I wasn't planning to stream today but
I went on leech s I saw there was a
monthly bowl with arena whenever there's
a monthly arena I I think an effort to
to join it and then what else happened
yeah not too much else has happened
today oh but then then people just
started donating especially koi TV who I
think maybe left I don't think I said
goodbye to him but yeah it's been a good
day so far let's see what does crew 64
it saying oh he's gonna be home in 30
minutes well crew 64 is streaming later
so if anyone wants to watch him
feel free I really want a sack I'm just
gonna sack completely unsound but I mean
on sound moves lead to more exciting
positions okay he wants to run with the
king I could play queen h2 King F to
Bishop H favorite g1 rook g6 that looks
decent because he runs out of oh he
doesn't run out of things he has Queen
f1 in the end I wanted to do this this
this than he is this but then I have
this does this and I take that's
probably good let's start with rope g6 I
mean blacks down like a rook rook for
two pawns if I win a piece back it
should be okay I need to continue
streaming I need to continue or you need
me to continue because there's a big
difference
what I need to do is walk the dog who's
just been sleeping the whole time okay
let's take that you guess my location by
the sunlight yeah actually I didn't
realize how like white my face is I know
there's a way to like adjust the
settings I'm gonna keep Queens on the
board
he can't take my bishop because his rook
would be hanging I mean I want to play
queen bee - but this Knight is
surprisingly useful on a4 I'm just
preventing my queen from infiltrating
but regardless it's a good position I
mean I have I have two pawns for the
exchange I'm not losing this Bishop to
play Bishop h3 I have two bishops have
the time advantage what kind of dog do I
have you should be able to see the dog
right yeah you see the dog this is my
dog right there he's a west highland
terrier pretty small and white and most
of the time he's pretty sleepy I want to
take on g1 and then if he takes my queen
plate oh wait what I didn't mean to do
that
take back I meant to draw an arrow
I didn't mean to play Queen e4 oops if
he doesn't give me a take back I'll try
and Mike I'll play him at least this is
casual okay wait another take tack no
wait I don't want to offer a draw take
back downward is heaven just cheering
for some reason okay well thank you so
the opponent who I can't mention his
name
um yeah let's retreat the Queen cause
it's still like an interesting fight I
know how I must live Queenie for I was
trying to draw an arrow I just clicked
I guess wow I'm so popular South
Carolina I'm not going to answer that
I'll call him back after I finish well
it's my 84 who's from South Carolina
anyone in the chat from South Carolina
okay let's do this and then this I don't
even have the chat open okay I'm going
to remove his night this is going to be
an interesting fight because my bishops
just so pointless
my fate currently um can I get away with
g v g5 he takes Queen e1 king of four
start with a quiet move try and make him
think
and now g5 I just want to activate this
Bishop I just bring it to g7 and not
trade Queens oh he wants to trade Queens
well let's not trade Queens I have Queen
h2 and then Bishop g7 and all I need to
do is like check the King may be Queen
here
and then here Wow his queen so annoying
sounds like he keeps attacking my queen
I really don't want to trade Queens stop
it
let's do this I feel like we've been
here before else play Queen a one and
queen a seven that he didn't see that
coming and now I'm gonna try and go in
for the kill
this is a plan Queen have two meats
might be a hard plan to achieve okay she
still wants a Queen trade um but now I'm
attacking his rook
oh I'm winning the rook because if he
plays King EE to hide Queen c2 check
well that's nice that's taking a little
less than 500 Queen moves and good thing
there's increments don't really have to
worry about time oh I could pull it Bend
find gold and just get a bunch of
bishops straight Queens oh no I wanted
promote to a bishop and then get one two
three four five I want to get seven
bishops GG all that was exciting
okay um anything to do yeah I have to
call back the person who called me oh my
gosh Wow
so yesterday I ordered a new microphone
cuz this guy I'm about to go really soon
I just want to share a story so this guy
broke like last week like it just
stopped working when I plugged it in it
would make this like terrible sound I've
had it for like just over a year so I
filed a ticket to try and get like a
replacement because I thought it was
under warranty I didn't hear back from
them since since last week and I just
got the message today saying that that
they're gonna ship me a new one but
yesterday I ordered a new microphone
from the same company but it's the
different microphones now I'll have two
microphones coming which maybe is a
blessing in disguise because a new one I
ordered is smaller it's more portable
something I can travel with so anyway
that's the story I'm gonna return my
headset cuz this this thing I think is
not the best quality I think the
microphone is too close to my mouth i I
don't know if it's still making that
weird buzzing sound I think it was Acts
villager who is telling me that like the
sound was being weird sometimes so
anyway I need to walk the dog I have
stuff to do today and it still is doing
the buzzing sound okay well hopefully
this is the last dream with the headset
because microphone should arrive
tomorrow or at the very latest the next
day is anyone streaming now no one's
streaming
uh I still want to raid someone oh thank
you blazing heart for you for the cheer
backup mic tip funds appreciate that oh
I think yeah I think what I realize it
only makes a buzzing sound if you're
listening with headphones like if you're
listening through a speaker it doesn't
make the buzzing sound which is really
strange but oh I could raid myself is
that possible raid I am Rosen
you cannot raid your own channel Wow
twitch is good with the special cases a
streamer
okay watch streamers I mean we could
raid a we took this lonely guy who I
sort of recognized because he was
screaming the bullet tournament and
people are challenging me I'm sorry
people have to wait but he's a Russian
streamer so does he speak Russian
oh he's offline nevermind jugen know he
looks also kind of foreign yeah the only
thing I'll say is crew 64 will be here
later he's a good friend
/ rival streamer so watch out for him
later I'll be back in the future
tomorrow
at like 2 or 3 p.m. Central Time and
then I'll set a schedule for the coming
week ok bye guys have a good day how do
I end there we go